oculto entre otras casas al final de un
callejón Un refugio donde la comunidad
lgbtq más vive en la sombra hace cinco
años su padre echó a Benson de casa al
descubrir su orientación sexual era solo
un joven estudiante de secundaria la
nueva ley me afecta mucho
por ejemplo no puedo ir andando a
ninguna parte
incluso nuestros vecinos nos amenazan
con matarnos
no estoy seguro aquí hay mucha más
homofobia no me siento seguro
tras un caso de pederasta entre un
profesor y un niño en enero una fiebre
homófoba se apodero del país las
autoridades y los medios de comunicación
asociaron este acto directivo con la
comunidad lgbtq más a finales de marzo
pasado del parlamento buganés votó a
favor de una ley que calificó de ante
gay una vez se aprueba este proyecto de
ley reforzaremos su aplicación para
garantizar que los homosexuales no
tengan lugares en lugar
si el presidente decide probar este
texto Benson se arriesga a la cadena
perpetua una pena ya prevista en el
código penal pero nunca aplicada e
incluso a la pena de muerte
va de refugio en Refugio su posesión más
preciada una foto de su madre que sigue
apoyándolo
mi madre siempre ha estado ahí para mí
incluso cuando mi familia descubrió mi
sexualidad
me escondió de mi padre todos me
perseguían mis hermanos Mis parientes
solo mi madre estuvo a mi lado
en 2020 una redada policial tuvo como
objetivo su refugio y los residentes
fueron enviados a prisión durante 50
días Henry activista de Derechos Humanos
estaba entre ellos esta vez quiere
evitar la detención y se prepara Para
mudarse pese las camas desmontadas todo
está ahí solo estamos esperando el
dinero para irnos
los vecinos ya han atacado a nuestros
miembros e incluso les han pegado casi
hasta matarlos nuestro casero sabe
Quiénes somos las autoridades y los
vecinos También estamos en peligro no
podemos quedarnos estamos en peligro en
2009 y 2014 se votaron otros proyectos
similares antes de ser anulados por el
presidente o el tribunal constitucional
cada vez se reaviva una ola de odio pero
Henry sigue luchando y acude cada día a
distintos lugares que aceptan a su
comunidad creen que ser gay no es
africano
dicen que es una abominación vivir cerca
de ellos por eso no nos quieren
Henry dirige su propia clínica de barrio
en campana una de las pocas abiertas a
personas lgbtq más pero los pacientes
son escasos la gente tiene miedo piensan
Y si voy a esta clínica y las
autoridades hacen una redada me llevaría
la policía hemos perdido algunos de
nuestros pacientes por culpa de la
situación
Amanda y Harry dos mujeres transexuales
quieren salir del país una de ellas es
trabajadora sexual ya ha sido agredida
varias veces
desde que se aprobó la ley la gente de
su entorno las rechaza ahora mismo tengo
problemas con mi novio no está a gusto
se queja y me dice si te detienen a ti
tendrán que detenerme a mí también
me escondo todo el tiempo ya ni siquiera
trabajo
nuestras vidas corren peligro y no
podemos hacer nada no tenemos a dónde
huir a dónde ir
la última vez que me detuvieron fue muy
brutal me golpearon e incluso me
desnudaron
como cientos de personas las dos mujeres
buscan asilo en un país occidental la
leía aún debe ser firmada por el
presidente duandes antes de que pueda
aplicarse en la televisión sudafricana
yoguar y Muse Beni explica que considera
desviadas a las personas lgbtq más este
es el error de los países occidentales
porque vienen y quieren obligarnos a
decir
la homosexualidad es genial
Ahora ven las repercusiones
ellos son los que nos provocan una
opinión presidencial compartida por la
mayoría de los representantes electos e
incluso por la comisión de derechos
humanos de uganda dentro del Código
Penal hay un aparato llamado delito
contra el orden natural que prevé
castigos para la homosexualidad sería
arrogante por nuestra parte cuestionar
la sabiduría del parlamento que aprobó
por unanimidad este proyecto de ley
Bueno
pero las ong de Derechos Humanos afirman
que la Constitución debe proteger la
integridad de todos los ciudadanos
Claire diarigaba activista y abogada
Lleva años luchando contra estos
proyectos de ley los ugandeses hemos
aprendido a odiar nos han radicalizado
para que temamos a una comunidad que no
ha hecho nada malo
cada vez que este gobierno del
parlamento quieren distraer a los
grandeseces de algo como un escándalo de
corrupción ponen sobre la mesa una ley
contra la homosexualidad
el tribunal constitucional que ya
rechazó un proyecto anterior podría ser
tomado por los defensores de los
Derechos Humanos si se aplica la ley